will kane co-host of fox and friends
weekend
is in focus now will
what stood out to you
what stood out to me i think is the
phrase that was uttered by senator tom
cotton in those clips you just played
the president is detached from reality i
don't mean that as an insult i mean that
as a reflection of reality
when he says that he has overperformed
in his first year i don't think you're
going to find maybe a single american
who would agree with that assessment of
his first year when he says that the
midterm report cards are going to come
back
positive for democrats and for his
administration he shows that he has no
grasp on what's happening in the real
world and it makes somewhat sense harris
i think that president biden and the
democrats for that matter have done a
good job of warping reality shaping
reality for the past couple of years
they've painted
the prior administration as the
reinvention of the ku klux klan they've
painted all their political opponents as
racist and they've been rewarded with
political power they've pumped the
american public full of fear over covid
and they have been rewarded with yet
more power so they have shaped reality
but reality is now rudely interrupting
this delusion whether or not it comes in
the form of russia or inflation or bad
poll numbers reality has a way of waking
you up and so his delusion his
detachment from reality is now becoming
obvious i think to the american people
look i described the press corps inside
the white house yesterday as hungrier
than normal and i'm interested to get
your grade on how they did first of all
there were a few softballs but there
were a lot of tough questions too let's
watch
did you over promise to the american
public what you could achieve in your
first year in office do you need to be
more realistic and scale down these
priorities now that legislation appears
to be
hopelessly stalled
can you now lay out your strategy to
protect voting rights i spoke to a
number of black voters who fought to get
you elected and now they feel as though
you're not fighting hard enough for them
why are you trying so hard
in your first year to pull the country
so far to the left
now i do want to note this will
not one question on the violent crime
crisis in this country and immigration
was brought up only two times
your take
my take is that is a performance which i
guess in the same way that we should say
president biden did a good job of
fielding questions for two hours that
should be commended he was out there for
two hours he should do that much more
often it should be much less scripted we
can give also faint praise nonpartisan
faint praise to the press for finally
pushing back a little
harris and look at the response by the
way from president biden i think the
minute that his reality by the way is
interrupted then he lashes out he blames
others for his problems we know he's
done that with the unvaccinated for a
year he blamed fox news i watched all
two hours he blamed fox news in
particular and
anyone who disagrees with him for not
not shaping the american public to his
delusions he blames uh everyone who
steps in his way republicans as you
pointed out the top of the show he has a
problem with democrats
but he didn't mention them by name this
time
no no he wouldn't even mention my party
yeah he did skip that part it's cinema
it's cinema and mansion two people with
d's beside their name they stand in the
way of his agenda not republicans he
lashes out over and over at anyone who
dares step up to challenge him and here
the media gave him just the slightest
bit of pushback maybe best real quick
harris may be best illustrated by the
moment where one reporter said hey why
are you calling your opponents bull
connor or george wallace and he said i
didn't say that he got angry right i
didn't say that read what i said he said
in correction i said they stand on the
side of bull connor and george wallace
you're not literally george wallace or
bull conor but you're with them i'm not
really sure how that makes his position
better but it did show his anger at
anyone that dare challenge him yeah that
part felt a little bit like well okay
well let's rehearse this part
because you know you're going to get
this question he was ready to go and and
we'll have to see how that works out for
him uh with
communities of color because as you
heard kristen welker from
nbc she pressed him on how the numbers
have come down for people who support
him who are people of color and they
were a primary reason of why he got into
the white house all right i want to move
to this you mentioned the midterms a
moment ago and president biden yesterday
insisted he will do what he can to help
his fellow democrat lawmakers in the
upcoming elections
i'm going to be deeply involved
in the off these off year elections
we're going to be raising a lot of money
we're going to be out there making sure
that we're helping all of those
candidates
i don't know with those poll numbers i'm
not sure if that's good news for them
but anyway
even cnn reporting that biden has not
made himself available to talk with
democrat campaign committee chairs about
the midterms despite their requests
biden's low approval rating and the wave
of democrat retirements has the party
worried about november 8th
292 days from today yes we're counting
will
you know since you bring up cnn i want
to tie this back into our last question
our last conversation about lashing out
at those that disagree with you and who
you blame for your problems there was a
cnn pundit the other day who was a
high-level politico that ran several
administrations communications who said
the democrats don't have bad leaders
they have bad followers so now we're to
the point of not only blaming the media
or the unvaccinated we're blaming
democratic voters for not following
along with this administration's
delusions it's truly remarkable no if
i'm a democrat harris i don't want
president biden campaigning for me you
brought up minority voters those those
polls the most stark thing harris is
that quinnipiac poll that says yes yes
yes he's 33
with the american public he's 25 percent
with independence he's 24 with young
people and 28 with latinos that is not
someone you want campaigning for you if
you're a democrat across this country
and then finally i'll say this harris
because of all of these reasons it's
just it's unforgivable that the
president now steps up to that podium
and begins to question the election
integrity how many days out did you say
we're
the democrats have spent years coming
after president trump for questioning
election results and here they are when
the shoe is on the other foot before the
election even takes place by a measure
of what seven eight months already
calling into question the midterm
elections yeah i mean that was just
stark opposition to anything that
democrats have been saying including him
up until this point
but i guess they're looking
it may not go their way
and so
by the way the white house press
secretary jinsaki was asked about that
uh last hour on america's newsroom and
so it is something that the white house
is going to have to deal with him saying
that
because the election as i said is
november 8th it's coming up and does the
president believe it's going to be fair
or not if he doesn't get the legislation
he wants if he doesn't get his way is he
going to say it didn't really happen the
way it should happen we'll have to cover
the news as it happens will kane great
to have you in focus hi brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now